how can small everyday changes in our
lives help us toward move toward
sustainability so I think that's the
only way to really move because the
radical change is rarely stick I mean
you might turn around diamond say
alright I'm going full 180 I'm full
consumer today and tomorrow I'm I'm full
zero waste but you try that for a day or
two it's like crash diets they hardly
work right and so we're talking about
sustainability that's really we're
talking about these small changes right
I think we underestimate the Wildfire
nature of it you know when you make a
small change than your partner might and
your children the people that you're
teaching how to live and interact in the
world your community and that multiplied
the the idea of these small changes
multiplied creates massive changes in
our ecosystem in our society so being
able to enact those small changes that
you can in a more excellent permanent
way is much more effective than reaching
for something that's just you know so
far out of your wheelhouse is so true
BAM when Mariah and I we were in Tokyo
like everything is so a Mack and
immaculate like everything is so clean
it's like it's like five New York cities
but like just scrubbed clean thirty-nine
it's unbelievable but like because
you're in that environment it's like
when I'm walking down the street and
there's a piece of trash on the ground
like it actually motivates me to like
pick up the trash I don't know who threw
it down it doesn't matter but I'm like
oh like this city's so beautiful like I
want to help keep it that way
so yeah totally yeah it totally rubs off
it can create yeah that wildfire effect
you know about the broken window theory
so in 90s New York City like they were
working on on fixing it up and making
neighborhoods nicer and then people
judge did this in South Bend over the
last decade where we realized like if
there was a window that's broken or a
piece of trash that's on the ground we
can do one of two things we can either
fix that or it's going to leave the more
broken windows and what what we realized
through urban planning and
urban esthetic they realize like oh we
fixed the one window
all of a sudden other buildings nearby
start fixing what they have going on the
areas that we don't fix though they
start to get graffiti in fact Buddha
judge had this thing in in South Bend
they have 24-hour graffiti removal so
anything they hit a hotline you call and
if there's a graffiti they any time a
day will go and they have someone to go
remove that graffiti because that
graffiti leads to more graffiti and
there's a quick downward spiral to but
but you also realize that if you're a
graffiti artist you know that it's gonna
get taken down within 24 hours man I'm
gonna go to the next town over
yeah Banksy probably isn't gonna go to
South Bend the down the down side is
most graffiti artists aren't Banksy
right but by the way here's the thing
like most landlords would love for you
to put a Banksy on their building right
right but I they they also like they
don't want a random graffiti artist to
come by and and vandalize because that's
what most graffiti is and so I think the
same can be true just with with our
everyday lives we have our own sort of
broken windows whether it's the pajamas
in the morning or it is that's an
incremental change we're talking about
putting on regular pants instead of
pajamas that's an incremental change but
as you said it starts to spread like
wildfire you realize like oh I'm making
some of these changes and it doesn't
just spread in my own life other people
start to notice the whole the reason
this whole minimalism thing worked for
me and Ryan is because he came to me one
day and he said why the hell are you so
happy
he saw the sort of the fire blazing and
he was like oh hey tell me more about
this thing in the example of Japan is so
wonderful because that's how culture
actually is changed and once culture is
changed you can change policy you can
change you know everything kind of stems
from that and then really big radical
changes on a systemic level it can
happen but it starts at the individual
level how am i acting
my own life and my own family and my own
community and us all taking
responsibility for that
you